Of these questions. I think we talked
about the oh, this is chapter two.
Let's go to chapter four. Okay,
so we talked about belief, policy,
state. I'm not sure if we talked about
this question. In the discussion of
active inference in POMDP t belief
updating about policies, we find that
the posterior that minimizes the free
energy does the posterior at time t.
Oh, we did discuss this. Yeah, we did
discuss this last time. So this
question, I think we
did not discuss pi being a policy or a
model last time. Or did we? I think we
didn't get to this. Yeah, I don't think
we discussed that. All right, so we can
open it up and we'll start here, I
guess, with the most upvoted. So the
question reads, what is pi? On page 69,
the authors write, at each time step,
the current state is conditionally
dependent on the state at the previous
time and on the policy pi currently
being pursued. Then on page 71,
they write, thus we can interpret the
priors of equation 4.6 combined with the
likelihood of equation 4.5 as expressing
a model pi of a behavioral sequence. So
which is it, policy or model? And then
they suggest a rewrite of the sentence.
They say that, thus we can interpret the
priors of equation 4.6 combined with the
likelihood of equation 4.5 and the
transition probabilities b sub tau pi
as expressing a model for a behavioral
sequence where the model is a function
of policy pi. And then there's some
discourse here. So in this reframing,
can we say that the model simulates the
agent in the environment as if it had
taken the actions in the policy?
And I don't know who asked that
question. Oh, Eric, that was you.
That was your question. And then does
anyone want to maybe take a stab at
answering that question? Or we can
continue reading what was written here.
So what's written here says
that on page 69, the authors also say
policies here may be thought of as
indexing alternative trajectories or
sequences of actions that could be
followed. On page 71, they define the
likelihood in equation four five as a
matrix A that expresses the probability
of an outcome. They describe the priors
of equation 4.6 as the prior over the
initial state vector D, and beliefs
about how the state at one time
transitions to the state at the next
time, matrix B. And they also say that
the transitions are conditionally
dependent on the policy chosen. Because
of this conditional dependence, we can
see how the policy influences the model
and why the authors may use the terms
interchangeably.
So does anyone have any comments
there's?
I guess I would say that that answer
in discourse kind of agrees with
what I proposed, which is that strictly
speaking, we should treat the
pi as policy, but it
behaves as a model. Once it's executed,
it's implemented. Then the
model has become a function of the
policy that's been we've seen so far.
So I'd say that's compatible
interpretation. So I think strictly
speaking,
it would be better if the text was
consistent and called Pi policy and
then say, yeah, the model is a function
of Pi. That'd be my interpretation.
Yeah, I definitely agree with that. I
think that the model is policy specific,
but they could do a better job of I
mean, the variables as we've seen are so
ambiguous anyway, so it could definitely
be a lot better.
And by the way, about the topic of
consistency, actually I gave some
thoughts about the issue we were
discussing in yesterday's math learning
session and I also consulted some other
papers and active inference and in
all of them the notation for matrices
and vectors is used consistently,
as in almost every linear algebra
textbook. So I'm seriously beginning to
suspect that every instance of a matrix
or a vector not written in Bold face is
a typo either in chapters or appendices
because otherwise I really cannot find
any justification behind using two
different types of notation. So I'm
going to use this assumption as my prior
for the rest of the book, unless someone
has any belief updating observation she
wants to share.
So just to summarize, for the people
that weren't there yesterday, we had a
big debate about what does the Bold
typeface signify? And it wasn't so much
a debate, but just like trying to come
to a mutual understanding. So it's this
question here. Does bold lettering mean
this is a matrix, but seemingly also
many non bold letters are a matrix? Or
does bold lettering mean sufficient
statistics of as on these page examples?
And it really was yeah,
we couldn't come to a single unified
answer there because there are many
instances where it seems like it should
be a matrix, but it's not bold and there
are many instances where sufficient
statistics are used but it's also not
bold. So yeah, we couldn't really
conclude that, but I think I'll lead it.
That's a good assumption there.
So we also talked about this a little
bit last time, but we didn't really get
fully into this question. What is the
use of categorical distributions in
equation 4.5? The second line is
supposed to explain the cat notation,
but I have problems to understand the
advantage of the notation. Could someone
explain it in simple words? Does anyone
want to try to explain that? I can pull
up the equation.
Well, I think every regular matrix and
vector is by definition an
array of ordered elements. But in a
categorical distribution we don't
necessarily assign any specific order
to the elements. So the reason behind
using the categorical distribution might
be to just jettison
any orderness in the elements and
treat them as just an
unordered set of the probabilities.
I wrote an answer to this one if you
want to pull that up, so you can just
read that's.
So I hope this is helpful.
It's basically the way I see it is you
have the math, the math notation there,
but when you need to actually implement
that, you need to carry it out, then you
need to turn that into operations you
can perform. And so when you
say that A is this categorical
object, that means that you're turning
it into an actual matrix with elements.
And so the ordering is important,
actually, because the ordering of the
elements in the matrix says how that
matrix is going to apply to the objects
it applies to, which are the belief
state S, and then your observation O.
So basically
it says the way you carry out inferring
what O will be the probability of O
given a belief state is you do a matrix
multiply.
And because in
this example,
the states are not continuous, they're
categorical, then you need a categorical
matrix element in order to do map
from the categories of belief states to
the categories of observation states.
And those are both distributions that
gets transformed by the matrix.
Thanks, Eric, that was super helpful.
Does anybody have any further question
or comment on this one?
Sorry, Eric, but isn't the categorical
notation special case of multinomial
distribution? Categorical distribution
special cases of multinomial
distribution?
I don't know that. Yeah,
because that was my understanding that
the main difference between any
categorical distribution and well,
I mean,
for instance, of course you're right
that in any matrix we necessarily have
some ordered elements in order for us to
be able to compute the math on those
matrices. But on the other hand,
for categorical distributions, at least
that was my understanding that we don't
necessarily treat them as
ordered elements, such as, I don't know,
the ordered vectors or ordered matrices
as the normal matrix.
Because if that was the case, well,
we could just designate this
distribution as just a regular matrix.
Right. So I don't get what's the reason
behind using the notation
here, cat A or cat,
instead of just using the. Name of the
matrix?
Steven, can you mute you're super loud
over there.
Sorry.
Yeah, I guess so.
The mathematical notation doesn't have
an ordering. It just says distribution
is related to another distribution
through this
relation. And when you get to the
mechanics of how do you do that? That's
where you care that you have the matrix
with the vector ordering. So,
yeah, I don't know what cat A
actually means other than it's just
describing it. I don't think it's like
an operator, I think it's just saying
what it is. Does that make sense?
Steven, if you're trying to talk, we
can't hear.
What.
I feel like Steven is trying to share an
idea with us, but is unable to
communicate effectively through the
technological affordances he's been
given at the time. Like the gain on your
mic is way up or something, so it's
picking up more background noise than
you're.
Just looking at this equation. Can you
guys hear me okay?
Yeah. Okay, so just looking at this
equation, the second part,
it's like the,
it's like an ordered matrix A-I-J where
the probability of the observations are
equal to index I and the states equal to
index j, something like that.
I don't know, it looks like it is
ordered. Yeah, the matrix itself is
ordered. Yeah. And so the second line is
actually by how the authors are defining
this cat A. So cat A represents this
ordered matrix AIG?
Yeah,
that's at least what it says in the
textbook.
So it says the likelihood expressing the
probability of observations conditioned
on time tau given states s conditioned
on time tau is equal to the categorical
distribution A.
Sorry. Yaku, go ahead.
Sorry, my internet is lagging a bit, so
there might be a delay and I might break
off. But I just want to comment that I
think that the cat notation is really
just to reinforce
the notion that it's in discrete time.
But I think it's kind of redundant in
this case because since we know that we
are in discrete time, we could have just
written a bolt to
signify that it's a matrix and where
it's a matrix, it's probably not going
to be a continuous distribution anyway.
So I think cat bold A and bold
A is pretty much interchangeable.
So I think that some of the new math is
using some of the affordances from
category theory more like some of the
newer things. And I think the forward
direction that Karl and Thomas and some
of the people that really helped derive
and advance some of this math, I think
that they're going to be leveraging
category theory methods like the
renormalization group and the pullback
attractor more in the future. And so
that might be also part of the reason
that they are moving toward this
categorical notation. So just a little
maybe foreshadowing there too.
May I just make one additional note
about this categorical distribution?
Well, the thing that confused me about
this concept of categorical distribution
is the Wikipedia's definition of it,
because here it says there is no innate
underlying ordering of these outcomes,
but numerical labels are often attached
for convenience in describing the
distribution. So that was my confusion.
I don't think it would be the first time
that we've seen traditional mathematical
notation slightly and somewhat abused in
active inference. Probably also won't be
the last. But definitely I think it's
a point that we can put forward to the
authors for additional clarification.
If there's no further anybody has
anything else to say about the
categorical distributions here, if not,
we can move on to maybe the next
question.
So this next question reads in message
passing, is there a decay of information
as the distance between the variable X
and individual Markov blanket
constituents increases? Is
implementation of information decay? In
message passing an option for model
implementation? I think that this is a
super interesting question and it's
something that I've thought about before
a lot. But I think,
yeah, let me open it up to anyone and
see if they want to address it before we
can get into some of the discourse.
Well, doesn't that all depend upon the
chain of loss between one stage of the
message passing and another? And if you
have no loss, then you don't have any
decay. But the more stages you have
where you get a little bit of diffusion
or loss, then you're going to have
decay, just a function of the
parameters. Well, so are messages passed
within the same Markov blanket or
between things that are partitioned with
their own Markov blanket? That's another
question.
I also agree with Eric, as I mentioned
yesterday. I also believe that,
well, this information loss
is not accounted for at least inherently
in active inference formalism because
it depends on the specific situations
that those
information propagate because otherwise
we couldn't have any general
or all encompassing formalism for
accounting for these information loss.
So we see in this box they
talk about Markov blankets and the
message passing. So here is variational
message passing. This involves messages
from all constituents of the Markov
blanket of X, including the parents via
the conditional probability of X given
its parents and the children. The latter
depends on the conditional probability
of the children of X given all of their
parents, which include X. Note the
expectation includes the children and
parents of the children as parents of
the children x, we divide by Q of X to
ensure the expectation includes the
blanket only. So I think
the messages are like all of the things
inside of the blanket, send a message to
something else in another blanket. At
least that's how I interpret this
way of active inference. And so it would
make sense that from
within the blanket, does everyone have
the same is there like a high degree of
mutual information shared in the Markov
blanket? I think conditional dependence
is what qualifies as
conditional independence is what
establishes the markup blanket. So
within constituents under the blanket,
do they all have all of the same
information all of the time? That's
something that's kind of confusing to
me. One thing I'd point out about
figure 4.3,
so in the previous chapters we
have this picture of there being the
world and your model of the world and
your model of the world is a Markov
blanket itself and it interfaces with
the world through the observation
variables and the action variables.
This picture doesn't have that
breakdown. So it's got state there, but
it doesn't say is that state all
internal state? Is it external state or
a mixture of them? And it apparently is
mixture because you've got policy that
can affect state, which means that
you're going to have action, is going to
be part of the state transition as well
as and then you have the observations
coming out the bottom. But I
think if we're going to talk about
Markov blankets, then I would like to
see this picture be exploded into the
state of the machine versus the state of
the external world and how those
interact with one another. Because
that's what the markup blanket does. Is
it compartmentalizes the information?
Well, that is the POMDP model and
Figure 4.3 and this really Figure
4.4 makes me scratch
my head quite a bit. This is the image
that is going to represent message
passing in a Bayesian framework. And so
the caption says on the right
dependencies between different variables
in the belief updating scheme outlined
in the main text. Intuitively, current
beliefs about states under each policy
at each time are compared with those
that would be predicted given beliefs
about states at other times, this is
one. And current outcomes to calculate
prediction errors. These errors then
drive updating and beliefs, this is two.
Given beliefs about states under each
policy we can then calculate the
gradients of the expected free energy.
This is three. These are combined
with the outcomes predicted under each
policy omitted from the figure. To
compute beliefs about policies, this is
four. And then using a Bayesian model
average, we can then compute posterior
beliefs about states averaged over
policies. This is five.
And this kind of leads us into the next
question. But I am not able to really
interpret this Figure 4.4 in any better
way. So if anybody has like a plain
English description of how
this works, I would love to hear it.
We can talk a little bit about a
question that was raised about this
figure and also about this squiggle
sigma because there's a great I
don't know, we kind of had a hard time
figuring out the equation and the
squiggle sigma and what that actually
stands for. So we could move to that
discussion because I think it's maybe
related to this message passing
discussion. But let's read the discourse
here first on the message
passing question.
So in the discourse,
what is the mechanism for signal decay?
So this is information decay,
implementation of information decay. Is
the message a thing behaving as an
active inference agent itself or a
special piece of information not
behaving as an active inference system
itself? Is there a blanket impedance
mismatch? I think Brock contributed
this. I'm not sure if he's here today.
And then message passing as described
through active inference usually is a
hierarchy, not a lateral transfer like
within constituents in the blanket. So
the key thing here is how you define the
markup blanket. Either there's a
partition between particles, cells or
whatever, or there's no partition in
blanket and everything under the blanket
is conditionally dependent. Does
conditional dependence preclude message
passing? Our message passed within nodes
in the same blanket. I have not seen
this and would love if someone pointed
me to some references. So that was me.
I wrote the last part because I haven't
seen message passing under the same
Markov blanket. It's always been like
from one Markov blanket partitioned
object to a different Markov blanket
partitioned object. But that
moves us into if anybody has any
comments, feel free. Well, I would say
message passing is used to do the
inference. So it's within a markup
blanket. That's pretty common, I think
the way message passes is used.
So here, as it's shown in Figure 4.4,
although this is totally beyond me to
describe here, this is a temporal
message passing. So it's like from one
time point to another time point and
then on the left it depicts the
hierarchical, like a hierarchical
expansion collapsing over time steps but
that a higher level network might
predict the states and policies at the
lower level and use these to draw
inferences about the context in which
these occur. So the way that I've always
seen the message passing used is from
one time point to another or from one
layer of a hierarchy to the next layer
of a hierarchy and I've not seen it
passed within constituents under the
same Markov blanket. So Eric, if you
have references that depict some kind of
message passing in active inference
that's not through time steps or through
hierarchical levels, I would love to see
that because I have not seen it. Well,
I would just go back to box 4.1 where
they talk about the variational message
passing and how you get information.
And I would say within a blanket you've
got various nodes and they have this
hierarchical parent child relations and
in order to do inference about, hey,
what's our belief in one of these
parents? You got to kind of go up and
down and say well, what are the children
of that and what do the other parents
think? So that's all within a single
Markov blanket, the parents and
children, the hierarchical relation and
the message passing happens to circulate
that information within the blanket.
That's how I read.
And I also put a link here to a paper by
Champion at all in which they have
actually explicitly defined the active
inference, or better say, reformulated
the active inference formalism according
to variation of message passing.
And if you just give me a second, I can
find exactly the place where
they have stated this in
plain English.
You can continue with the other
questions if you like, but I need a
moment to check this paper. Sure, yeah,
I'll check it out also and yeah, thank
you for that. So like when I'm reading
this variational message passing, this
involves messages from all constituents
of the Markov blanket of X. So the
message is coming from all the
constituents in the blanket, but it
doesn't say where the message is going.
So it does make sense, I guess, that
it's an interchangeable or within would
be a better word than from within all
constituents of the Markov blanket
because I was reading it as like the
message is coming from everything under
that blanket, which I guess is an
incorrect interpretation.
So thank you Eric for pointing that out
because I was like what?
So this is a really hard question that
I looked to try to answer. Actually a
bunch of us looked yesterday a lot. So
it says in equation four point ten, the
sigma variable, squiggle sigma,
we'll call it whatever, I'm not sure how
to say it is used to describe the
difference between the natural log of
observations conditioned on policy and
preferences. What is the function of
this variable? It also comes up in
figure 4.4, the message passing figure
we're just looking at, and it would be
great to have a verbal description of
this figure, what other papers or
equations use this squiggle sigma? And
we looked at length, like through the
entire textbook, through the other
chapters it refers to like we'll unpack
this later in chapter seven. We looked
through chapter seven, we looked through
the appendices, we saw a variable that
almost looks like that, but I think it's
a gamma. It looks like a little bit more
fancy than this squiggle sigma and could
not find that at all.
So we went to unpack equation 410.
And
so here is the equation
itself. I'm not
sure how to pull this up next to the
actually maybe I'll put it up here,
419.
And this equation four point ten is a
rewriting of equation 4.7 in linear
algebraic form. So we tried to
kind of unpack this a little bit. So the
first line states the prior probability
for each policy. This is that pi sub
zero is equal to the soft maps function
sigma times the negative expected free
energy G. And so that's
this first line. The next line is the
expected free energy conditioned on
policy g sub pi is equal to the entropy
or negative expected log probability h
times the states conditioned on policy
and time, which is S sub pi times tau
or both of those sub pi and tau plus the
observations conditioned on policy and
time. This O sub pi times tau times
the beliefs conditioned on policy and
time, which is a squiggle sigma maybe
sub pi times tau. So we were kind of
unsure if beliefs is correct here. We
kind of pulled that out of the legend
for figure 4.4. But if anybody knows,
and just to maybe unpack that a little
bit more, the beliefs conditioned on
policy and time, the squiggle sigma,
sub pi times tau is equal to the
difference between the observations
conditioned on policy and time o sub pi
times tau and preferences conditioned on
time C sub pi or sub tau. So we were
unsure if belief is correct here also.
And so if anybody knows if beliefs is
the difference between observations and
preferences, that would be great to have
some kind of feedback or input here
because we couldn't really reach a
conclusion.
Well, I guess one tiny
step toward figuring this out, I would
say, is that that funny squiggle thing
there has to do with the C.
We've got, we've got this probability
of observations given C and C is this
mysterious object that expresses
preferences which has also been under
explained. So if you look at the two
terms of the expected
free energy G as a function of
functional policy in 4.7, and then look
at how it looks like in four point ten,
that sigma thing there,
we've got the dot, which I guess is a
multiplier by observation. So that's the
same as that's like saying your
probability of observation given C. So
that's, I guess, a matrix multiplier
version of this log probability of
sequence of observations given your
preference prior C.
Yeah, so they do unpack. It a little bit
more in equation 4.7 or it seems
to be like maybe we could extrapolate
from 4.7 if this is beliefs, because it
is this natural log of observations
minus the natural log of preferences.
But up in the top that just the free
energy is the entropy or
maybe the dot product of the entropy
times the states plus the observations
times or the dot product of the
observations and maybe beliefs here
I can't recall a mathematical
representation of belief ever using this
squiggle sigma before. And I looked
through the recent Ryan Smith paper and
I looked even at the message passing
paper by Friston and I was not able to
really get any additional references
to this squiggle sigma at all. So why do
you say belief as opposed to
preferences? Well, so it says here
that the squiggle sigma
is equal to the difference between the
natural log of the observations
conditioned on policy and time and the
natural log of the preferences at a
certain time. So the sigma is defined
by the natural log of the preferences,
but it's more than just the preferences.
Does that make sense? Eric? Yeah,
but that's not claim as belief, right?
That's observations versus preferences,
right.
From expected deviation or how much risk
is being taken relative to the policy
that's applied.
The dot product is between the
observation and that wiggle sigma,
right, which is in turn like,
okay, this is what I've observed, this
is what I expected. So it's like a
divergence between two. So how much more
risk am I taking and how far is this
pushing me away from my free from
minimizing free energy?
So maybe it's something.
Whereas belief is wrapped up in the s
because that's your model of the world.
So risk is maybe how the squiggle sigma
is defined. But then if you look into
this figure 4.4 like that's, that's why
we used belief. So here, let's, let's
I'll, I'll pull it up right now.
So I'm not sure how easy this is to see.
But before we get to number one
here, we have like on the right hand
side the second to lowest level is
states conditioned on policy and time.
I think I'm going to read it off this
bigger screen. Yeah. States conditioned
on policy and time at different time
steps. So like the current time is in
the middle, the forward time step is on
the right and the backward time step is
on the left. And so that's what we start
with. So intuitively, current beliefs
about states under each policy at each
time are compared with those that would
be predicted given beliefs about states
at other times. So maybe
beliefs is this f and that's kind of
what Eric was saying because it's
defined earlier. This epsilon here is a
prediction error, right? So what we come
to after step one, it says and current
outcomes to calculate prediction errors.
That's what we arrive at after number
one. The errors then drive updating in
the beliefs. That's number two. So here
we go from the current state at the
present time to a prediction error that
drives the belief updating at this
forward time step after number two. And
then it says given beliefs about states
under each policy, we can then calculate
the gradients of expected free energy.
Three. So what gives us this gradient of
expected free energy? Is it this s
sub tau plus one? Or is that a tau? I
think that's a tau. Yeah.
So is it a future state not conditioned
on policy? Or here we get to this
squiggle sigma. So it's a squiggle sigma
conditioned on policy and time plus one.
So it looks like a belief update there,
which is why belief made sense. So is
that a risk update? Is that a possible
interpretation there in this message
passing figure?
Well, they say it's a gradient,
which means it's saying how much do we
have to change our policy,
I think in order to get our objectives
yeah. Gradient makes sense to me.
It's how much information you've gained,
right? So if you actually
look at the change in the state with
respect to so I apply some force,
or let's just take a simple example.
If you have an actuator that just
applies force and all
it does is it moves forward and has to
follow a trajectory. So the error
is at each time step. If it's a
deterministic system, you expect it to
follow a straight line and it's
deviating up way. So that's epsilon. So
you have to update, okay, this is how
far up I am from the state that I'm
supposed to be. So I need to apply
slightly less force or maybe force
in a different direction.
It's also how much I have to overcorrect
in the future depending on what I've
done currently, right? It's not just if
I've applied some force right now, I
might deviate in the opposite direction
and I have to come back, so I have to
figure out how much force to apply. So
that's why I said risk or. Yeah,
gradient, you would have to take the
change with respect to the state change
with respect to the error. So yeah,
that would be one interpretation of it.
Right, so it's a gradient of the state
change with respect to what you have
done. So I
also heard the term information gain in
there. Yeah,
I'm just generally saying. So in neural
networks, for example, we would have
some sort of loss function and we would
calculate the weight change with respect
to the change of the loss function.
Right. So, like, I have a weight vector
and then this particular example
is giving me a certain amount of
gradient and I need to minimize this
gradient. So I need to change the
weights in turn so the gradient actually
interfaces between this loss function
and all these weights. So effectively,
the gradient passes on information as to
how much the weight has to change in
order to minimize that loss function.
That's why I said information.
And also, as a side note, I think
I found this sigma in
Ryan Smith's paper too, and it is
defined as the expected prediction
error.
So the expected prediction error versus
the actual prediction error. And they
distinguish it from epsilon in the Ryan
Smith paper because I did look at that,
but I didn't find it in there. Yeah,
it's in equation 27 under
the section outcome prediction errors.
You it may be that the expected means
it's an expectation over the Q
distribution, which is your distribution
over belief
states.
Yeah, that's great. Ali and I
and some others worked on this yesterday
a lot and it's great that it kept you up
late at night, clearly, Ali, so you went
digging around for some more
information. That's awesome. Yeah,
great. Okay, perfect. Well, that
resolves that very well. And then
let's get into maybe the next question.
In equation 4.16, the X
has a dot over. It changed through time
but not the Y data.
So there's some discourse on this.
Or maybe we should go to the next
question, actually, because it's maybe
more related. So, Figure 4.6 uses an
epsilon for prediction error as
described in equation 4.21. Is this
predictive processing framing a part of
the active inference model or is this
presented for contrast to illustrate the
similarities and differences between
active inference and predictive
processing? So this is equation 4.1
and this is the epsilon, but I think we
see it way before equation 4.21. Like
it's even there. In equation 4.4,
it says this predictive coding schema is
part of the active inference model
illustrating the hierarchical structure
of predictions and beliefs. The authors
say one way to think about this is as if
we had equipped a predictive coding
scheme with classical reflex arcs at the
lowest level of the hierarchy. And they
give this reference in this setting,
active inference is just predictive
coding plus reflex arcs. Does anybody
know what a reflex arc is? Because I'm a
little bit lost with respect to that or
have any comments on this prediction
area? Yeah, reflex arc is basically
the stimuli that doesn't go through the
sensory cortex.
I thought it was like a mathematical
construct.
Maybe you think of it as a control
system. No thinking.
It's just like you bang your knee.
Your foot goes up. That makes
sense. And it says, we minimize free
energy through action. And the only part
of the free energy that depends on
action is the lowest level of prediction
error. In this hierarchical schema,
action fulfills descending predictions
by minimizing the error between the
predicted and observed sensory data.
Any additional comments here about
predictive coding and active inference?
Or we can look at this equation 4.16.
The x has the dot over. It changed
through time, but not the y data. Y is
this. And here
the discourse says, the top equation
depends on f of x and v, which is a
deterministic function describing how a
hidden state changes over time. The
bottom equation depends on g of x and v,
which describes how data are generated
from a single hidden state. The tilde
indicates change through time. The dot
indicates the first order derivative.
Any comments here on this equation or
your question?
Maybe we can ask one more question, or
maybe a couple more. So here it says on
page 63, it says specifically, the
Bayesian brain helps us frame the
problems that an agent engaging in
active inference must solve broadly.
These are the problem of inferring
states of the world perception and
inferring a course of action planning.
Other than perception and action
planning, are there other tasks or
challenges that the brain or organisms
engage in? How would we know?
There's no discourse here, but let's
open it up and see what you guys think.
Yeah, people wonder, hey,
what's on that star out there?
That's neither? I don't know. Is that
inferring State of the world? I guess
not. Planning.
And it could just be a hallucination of
generative model. You're not really
measuring anything, you're just
measuring yourself over and over again.
That could be one thing.
Okay, so here there's another question
for each of the graphical models in
Figure 4.2. What is an intuitive example
for each structure?
One would be disease diagnosis.
So you have symptom that is causative or
predictive of some condition.
I think that was the example that they
gave in the text, right?
Or did we talk about this last week
maybe?
Yeah, I actually don't get the question
because each of them we have an example,
at least an example in the text.
Yeah, that's true.
And I think we're going to maybe see
more examples as we go through the book.
But just in case, if anyone wants to see
some more examples actually,
that paper, I put the link in the chat,
realizing Active Inference in Variation
Message Passing contains some more
examples for each of these diagrams.
This is a fun last question. Maybe it
says this reiterates that
active inference uses two constructs,
variational free energy and expected
free energy, which are mathematically
related but play distinct and
complementary roles. In your own words,
what are the definitions of variational
free energy and expected free energy?
And what role do they play individually
or together in active inference?
My view of expected free energy was
given a certain action that might be
taken. It might produce this or reduce
the free energy or something, or it
talks about some future reduction on
free energy or something like that.
Variational free energy is more
objective. I don't know how to put it.
It's like, okay, actual kinetic energy
versus perceived kinetic energy kind of
thing. So if
you're rolling down a hill,
like rolling down a hill, we can
actually measure the kinetic energy at
the bottom of the hill, right? If you
put the ball at the top, expected free
energy would be like using a model to
calculate that and then finding out
actually corresponds if you look the
model. At least that's my view.
So I don't know. I'm probably like I
think about this in a lot of different
ways, but I think about variational free
energy. I mean, this is one way to think
about it, is maximizing
the trade off between epistemic value
and pragmatic value right now and
expected for free energy is like
maximizing that difference at some point
in the future. So you can plan ahead.
It might be cold out, so I'm going to
take a jacket or like it's cold right
now, I'm going to put my jacket on.
That's how I think about the difference
between those two. So it's ten. Thanks,
everyone, for coming. I hope I didn't
muddle this up too much. Trying to be
substitute teacher for Daniel, and it's
ten. So we're going to have tools right
now in this room. But if anybody wants
to continue discussing these ideas and
gather, you're welcome to migrate up to
one of the different spaces.
Yeah, and I think we'll stop the
recording now, Alex, if you haven't